This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Malser watering, lemons are squeezing, and stomachs are growling. Of all the ads you see on TV or on billboards or on the sides of buses, an overwhelming number seem to be for food. This is our masterpiece. Boorshead of an gold turkey, eggs and sausage, hotcakes and butter. I see coaks in frosted glasses, fajitas sizzling on the grill. And longhorn, what's in season matters.
这里是99%隐形。我是罗曼·马尔斯。水流声、柠檬挤压声，还有肚子咕咕叫的声音。在电视、广告牌或公交车身上看到的广告中，绝大多数似乎都是关于食物的。这是我们的杰作。烤火鸡的胸脯肉、鸡蛋和香肠、煎饼和黄油。我看到了磨砂玻璃杯里的可乐，烤架上滋滋作响的法希塔。还有长角牛，当季的食材很重要。
A guy biting into the perfect hamburger on a sesame seed bun. He can breathe in perfectly cooked. But of course, you know, in real life, these foods don't look like they do in the ads. I'm here with a question from Isabel Abem from Toronto, Ontario. She asks, why does your food look different in the advertising than what's in the store? It's a great question, Isabel. We can ask that a lot.
一个人咬下一口芝麻面包里的完美汉堡。他可以呼吸到完美烹饪的味道。但当然，你知道，在现实生活中，这些食物看起来并不像广告里那样。我这里有一个来自安大略省多伦多市伊莎贝尔·阿本的问题。她问，为什么食物在广告里看起来和店里卖的不一样？这是一个很好的问题，伊莎贝尔。我们经常被问到这个问题。
And if you want to come with me, I'm going to take you across the street, and we're going to find out a bit more. In 2012, McDonald's Canada put out this video about the process they go through to photograph one of their burgers. What I'm gonna do is introduce you now to Noah, who's our food stylist. And here I think that's important to note that all the ingredients that Noah uses are the exact same ingredients that we use in the restaurant. So, the video follows food stylist Noah as he painstakingly selects the perfect slices of onion and pickle. He places them on the burger with tweezers and then precisely melts the cheese just so.
如果你想跟我来，我要带你穿过马路，我们要去了解更多。2012年，麦当劳加拿大公司发布了一段关于他们拍摄汉堡过程的视频。我现在要向大家介绍我们的食品造型师诺亚。这里我认为需要指出的是，诺亚使用的所有食材与我们在餐厅使用的完全相同。所以，视频记录了食品造型师诺亚如何精心挑选完美的洋葱和酸黄瓜片。他用镊子把它们放在汉堡上，然后精确地融化奶酪。
So I'm just melting down the cheese with my palate, right? Then he picks up a plastic syringe filled with ketchup and applies it with surgical precision. Then they photograph this fancy burger and Photoshop it to perfection. They place a picture of a real burger just ordered at McDonald's next to the image of this stylized burger. And the difference is striking. That's reporter Danny Lewis. I would like to eat the burger that no a styled and disempled.
所以我只是用我的调色板融化奶酪，对吧？然后他拿起一个装满番茄酱的塑料注射器，以手术般的精确度涂抹。接着他们拍摄这个精美的汉堡，并用Photoshop将其修饰到完美。他们把一张刚在麦当劳点的真实汉堡的照片放在这张精修汉堡的图片旁边。差异非常惊人。那是记者丹尼·刘易斯。我想吃诺亚设计和组装的那个汉堡。
The other one, not so much. The last hundred years or so of food advertising have been shaped by this one simple fact. Real food looks bad on camera. Shooting food and even photographing food has always been fiendishly difficult in advertising. This is Terry O'Reilly. For decades, he was an ad man and he now hosts a radio show about advertising
另一个嘛，就不那么想吃了。过去一百年左右的食品广告一直被一个简单的事实所塑造：真实的食物在镜头前看起来很糟糕。在广告中拍摄食物，甚至只是给食物拍照，一直都极其困难。这是特里·奥莱利。几十年来，他一直是一名广告人，现在他主持一档关于广告的广播节目，
called Under the Influence. Terry says the challenges of shooting food are obvious. First of all, food is boring to look at when it's just sitting on a plate. Because food is generally static. Then, when you subject it to the hot lights of a studio, the food starts to wilt. It's just simple science.
名叫《受影响》。特里说，拍摄食物的挑战显而易见。首先，食物放在盘子里时看起来很无聊。因为食物通常是静态的。然后，当你把它置于摄影棚的强光下时，食物就开始枯萎了。这只是简单的科学原理。
And so advertisers have had to constantly walk this fine line between enhancement and fakery, trying all kinds of tricks to get food to look good. For the first half of the 20th century, well after photography was widely adopted, advertisers and magazines and newspapers relied heavily on illustration. The reason illustration was the preferred method was because you could completely control an illustration.
因此，广告商不得不不断地在增强效果和造假之间走钢丝，尝试各种技巧让食物看起来诱人。在20世纪上半叶，摄影技术被广泛采用后，广告商在杂志和报纸上仍然严重依赖插画。插画之所以是首选方法，是因为你可以完全控制插画。
In other words, there's no lighting issues, there's no wilting food issues. A marketer could really completely dictate what that food would look like right down to the strand of pasta with an illustrator. Then TV came along in the 1950s and 60s, and advertisers faced a whole new set of challenges. I'm going to show you how McDonald's builds a big-max sandwich. A lot of them didn't really understand how to shoot food in a compelling way. In this ad, the hamburger just sits there on the counter, while the ingredients get piled
换句话说，没有灯光问题，也没有食物枯萎的问题。营销人员可以完全决定食物的样子，甚至精确到意大利面的每一根线条。然后电视在20世纪50年代和60年代出现了，广告商面临着一系列全新的挑战。我要向你们展示麦当劳是如何制作巨无霸三明治的。很多人并不真正了解如何以引人注目的方式拍摄食物。在这个广告中，汉堡只是放在柜台上，而食材被堆叠
on. It starts here with a lightly toasted bun, and then a pure beef hamburger, sizzling hot. Without compelling visuals, there'd often be a voiceover, just describing the hell out of the food. Listing ingredients, telling you how good it tasted. And a little more sauce just for good flavor. Crisp, dill pickles, and a sesame seed crown. These early TV ads relied on relatively static shots.
上去。它从这里开始，一个轻微烤过的面包，然后是一个纯牛肉汉堡，滋滋作响。如果没有引人注目的视觉效果，通常会有画外音，极力描述食物。列出成分，告诉你它有多好吃。再加一点酱汁，味道更好。脆脆的莳萝酸黄瓜，还有芝麻面包顶。这些早期的电视广告依赖于相对静态的镜头。
Advertisers would use a wide-angle lens mounted on a camera, and it might zoom in and pan a little, but that's about it. There were lots of shots of boxes and labels. The food did just normal food stuff. You might see something being ladled out of a pot. You might see, you know, a spoon serving peas at a dinner table or serving cream corn at a dinner table. So that would be the extent of the motion. On top of the new challenges of television, food advertisers in the late 60s found themselves facing new scrutiny. The Federal Trade Commission was keeping a close eye on TV ads, following the now infamous Campbell Soup incident of 1968. They were introducing a new brand of soup that had a lot of vegetables in it, but the problem is the vegetables sink to the bottom.
广告商会使用安装在摄像机上的广角镜头，可能会变焦或平移一点，但仅此而已。有很多盒子和标签的镜头。食物只是做正常的食物动作。你可能会看到东西从锅里舀出来。你可能会看到，你知道，一把勺子在餐桌上盛豌豆或在餐桌上盛奶油玉米。这就是动作的极限。除了电视带来的新挑战，60年代末的食品广告商发现自己面临新的审查。联邦贸易委员会密切关注电视广告，继1968年臭名昭著的金宝汤事件之后。他们推出了一种含有大量蔬菜的新品牌汤，但问题是蔬菜沉到了底部。
So what they did was put a bunch of marbles in the bottom of the bowls just to hoist up the vegetables. When the FTC found out they threatened campals with legal action, the event led to a new push for truth in advertising. A lot of the old tricks advertisers had relied on in the past were now off the table. No more using glue instead of milk and cereal ads. No more substituting mashed potatoes for ice cream. But in the 1970s, food advertising took a radical turn. Food started moving. And that opened the door to all the fancy tricks we see in ads today. Shrimp, executing acrobatic flips, lobster claws, cracking open and slow motion, french fries bouncing across a table. Food wasn't static anymore.
所以他们做的是在碗底放了一堆弹珠，只是为了把蔬菜托起来。当联邦贸易委员会发现后，他们威胁要对金宝汤采取法律行动，这一事件导致了对广告真实性的新推动。广告商过去依赖的许多旧把戏现在都不能用了。不再在牛奶和麦片广告中使用胶水。不再用土豆泥代替冰淇淋。但在20世纪70年代，食品广告发生了根本性的转变。食物开始移动了。这为我们今天在广告中看到的各种花哨技巧打开了大门。虾在做杂技翻转，龙虾钳在慢动作中裂开，炸薯条在桌子上跳跃。食物不再是静态的了。
Food was flying. And we've got one man to thank for this new aesthetic, Albert Buton. He didn't want anything stagnant. Everything was always moving. He wanted to romance the food or whatever was there in front of him. This is Harry Drennan, who spent years working for Albert Buton. That's how he met his wife, set director Jackie Kanto. I've been in the film business for 35 years, 40. I don't want to say how long. The ads that Kanto and Brennan made with Putin until his death in 1996 were unprecedented.
食物在飞。我们得感谢一个人带来的这种新美学，阿尔伯特·布顿。他不想要任何停滞的东西。一切都在不断移动。他想浪漫化食物或他面前的任何东西。这是哈里·德雷南，他为阿尔伯特·布顿工作多年。他就是这样认识他的妻子，布景导演杰基·坎托的。我在电影行业工作了35年，40年。我不想说具体多久。坎托和德雷南在布顿1996年去世前与他制作的广告是前所未有的。
Working with clients like McDonalds, Burger King, and Coca-Cola, Putin invented a whole new visual language for food commercials and really pioneered the genre of advertising known as tabletop. Many of the terms and techniques that tabletop directors still use date back to Buton. For example, the prep shot, which tells the backstory of the product, showing all that goes into making the food.
与麦当劳、汉堡王和可口可乐等客户合作，布顿为食品广告发明了一种全新的视觉语言，并真正开创了被称为“桌面摄影”的广告流派。桌面导演至今仍使用的许多术语和技术都可以追溯到布顿。例如，准备镜头，它讲述了产品的背景故事，展示了制作食物的所有过程。
You know the ones, chopping a crisp head of lettuce, dicing some juicy red tomatoes. He would make these elaborate banquet things of raw ingredients, and that was his look. And creve shots. That's when the camera zooms way in and lingers on some tantalizing bite of food on the end of a fork. Sex in a way, you know, it's almost food porn, you know, it's made it all real tactile to you. And the hero shot, a last magnificent look at the food on the plate, ready to eat. Usually in the final seconds of the advertisement.
你知道那些镜头，切开一颗脆生菜，切碎一些多汁的红番茄。他会制作这些精致的原始食材宴席，这就是他的风格。还有特写镜头。那是摄像机放大并停留在叉子末端诱人的食物咬痕上。某种程度上很性感，你知道，这几乎是食物色情，你知道，它让你感觉非常真实。还有英雄镜头，最后一次在盘子里展示食物的壮观景象，准备好食用。通常在广告的最后几秒钟。
Buton's big breakthrough was that he didn't just describe the food and promise viewers it tasted good. He made them feel actual hunger with his images. His real thing is just food in itself, its essence is really sensual. You know what I mean? If you see a hamburger commercial, you really want to eat a hamburger,
布顿的重大突破在于，他不仅描述食物并向观众承诺它很好吃。他用他的图像让他们感受到了真正的饥饿。他真正的东西就是食物本身，它的本质确实是感性的。你知道我的意思吗？如果你看到一个汉堡广告，你真的想吃一个汉堡，
and that's the point of it, and I think that's what he introduced. And you'll never see it any other way now. Kanto and Drennan remember working long days and sometimes long nights to meet Butans high standards and to achieve his vision of flying food and mouthwatering close-ups they had to use a whole bunch of crazy tools like giant high-speed cameras that would burn through a thousand feet of film in seconds and make a ton of noise they start shooting and it was like,
这就是重点，我认为这就是他引入的东西。你现在永远不会以其他方式看到它了。坎托和德雷南记得为了达到布顿的高标准，为了实现他飞翔的食物和令人垂涎的特写镜头的愿景，他们不得不工作很长时间，有时甚至通宵。他们必须使用一大堆疯狂的工具，比如巨大的高速摄像机，它们会在几秒钟内烧掉一千英尺的胶片，并发出巨大的噪音。他们开始拍摄，就像是，
whew! It was just this all day long. It was something. These cameras were originally designed for the military to film rocket tests. It was used for ballistics, but we were the first ones to do it with food. Thanks to these cameras,
呼！整天都是这样。那真是一回事。这些摄像机最初是为军方拍摄火箭测试而设计的。它被用于弹道学，但我们是第一个用它来拍摄食物的人。多亏了这些摄像机，
Mutin could achieve super slow motion effects. He'd take a split second of time and look jury-aid in it. He'd have oranges splashed through a sheet of water. Condensation would drip down the side of a bottle. In order to get the perfect take, butan started designing strange, rube, goldberg sort of machines to help him get the job done.
布顿可以实现超慢动作效果。他会取一瞬间的时间并深入观察。他会让橙子溅过一层水。冷凝水会顺着瓶子侧面滴下。为了获得完美的拍摄效果，布顿开始设计奇怪的鲁布·戈德堡式的机器来帮助他完成工作。
These contraptions were called rigs. They ranged from simple spouts for liquid to machines that would drop pancakes into a perfect stack to catapults that would fling oranges across the studio. And sure, the production team could have just thrown the oranges by hand. But with rig, they could get the exact same results over and over, which meant fewer takes, which meant less time and less money spent. It also meant that they could achieve a certain level of precision and artistry. It was so much prettier than other people's work as far as I could see. It was beautiful and lighting. And then once he got into all the movement, I mean, he was ahead of the curve.
这些装置被称为“钻机”。它们范围从简单的液体喷口到将煎饼堆叠成完美堆叠的机器，再到将橙子弹射到摄影棚各处的弹射器。当然，制作团队本可以用手扔橙子。但有了钻机，他们可以一遍又一遍地获得完全相同的结果，这意味着更少的拍摄次数，这意味着更少的时间和更少的金钱花费。这也意味着他们可以达到一定程度的精确度和艺术性。据我所知，它比其他人的作品漂亮得多。它在灯光上很美。一旦他进入所有的动作，我的意思是，他走在了时代的前面。
ahead of the curve. To see how mutants techniques are still being used today, Danny went to my Guffin films in New York. Okay, so just quick descriptions. My Guffin does commercials for Red Lobster, Olive Garden, Starbucks, and a bunch of other restaurants. The day Danny was there, they were shooting a chicken sandwich. So they are shooting a chicken sandwich. Uh, here's what it looks like.
走在时代的前面。为了看看布顿的技术今天是如何被使用的，丹尼去了纽约的McGuffin电影公司。好的，快速描述一下。McGuffin为红龙虾、橄榄园、星巴克和其他许多餐厅制作广告。丹尼在那天，他们正在拍摄一个鸡肉三明治。所以他们正在拍摄一个鸡肉三明治。呃，看起来是这样的。
On a black slate with a little tray of chili peppers and garlic and stuff. A hand model stands near the edge of the table where the sandmatch is displayed. So now they're doing the crowning. Crowning means the hand model takes the bun and puts it on top of the sandwich. Just presses it there, elaborately, then takes the crown off. Between shots, a guy comes on with a fan brush to brush any crumbs off the top of the chicken. Then the crayon goes back on again. You might just put the crayon back on the sandwich please.
在一个黑色的石板上，旁边有一个放着辣椒、大蒜之类的小托盘。一个手部模特站在展示三明治的桌子边缘附近。现在他们正在做“加冕”。加冕意味着手部模特拿起面包，把它放在三明治上面。只是把它压在那里，精心制作，然后把顶盖拿走。在拍摄间隙，一个人拿着扇形刷子来刷掉鸡肉顶部的任何碎屑。然后顶盖又放回去了。请你把顶盖放回三明治上好吗。
It took them all day to film this sandwich. The whole shoot precisely orchestrated, relying on highly technical tools. Downstairs in McGuffin's prop room, there are all sorts of rigs sitting in storage, a lot like the ones that buton developed. But these are way more high tech. Riggers today use lasers and sensors and pre-programmed motors,
他们花了一整天时间拍摄这个三明治。整个拍摄过程经过精确编排，依赖于高技术工具。在McGuffin的道具室楼下，存放着各种各样的钻机，很像布顿开发的那些。但这些技术含量更高。今天的钻机操作员使用激光、传感器和预编程电机，
and depending on the shot or the rig, there can be some intense physics to take into account, like if you're trying to slice an onion in two while it's flying through the air. We break down the elements, so we know we've got to get an onion to a certain height. This is Anthony Derroberts. He's a special effects technician at McGuffin Films, and he designed a special rig just to get this shot. Everything's computer controlled, so when the onions in the right spot, these two sharp knives come through, split the onion and leave you with the sliced in the middle. And slices of onion,
根据拍摄或钻机的不同，需要考虑一些强烈的物理学因素，比如如果你试图在洋葱飞过空中时将其切成两半。我们分解元素，所以我们知道我们必须让洋葱达到一定的高度。这是安东尼·德罗伯茨。他是McGuffin电影公司的特效技术员，他专门设计了一个钻机来获得这个镜头。一切都是计算机控制的，所以当洋葱在正确的位置时，这两把锋利的刀就会穿过，切开洋葱，留下中间的切片。还有洋葱片，
artfully tumbling across a table, classic prep shot. But while Buton may have introduced rigs and action to tabletop, some directors like McGuffin's Nick Fugelstad are trying to get away from Buton's fantastical dreamscapes of flying shrimp and oranges. I think that's a little bit of an older point of view. For Nick Fugelstad, the idealized images of food that Budein tried to bring to his ads just
艺术地滚过桌子，经典的准备镜头。但是，虽然布顿可能将钻机和动作引入了桌面摄影，但一些导演，如McGuffin的尼克·富格尔斯塔德，正试图摆脱布顿那种飞翔的虾和橙子的梦幻梦境。我认为那是一个稍微老一点的观点。对于尼克·富格尔斯塔德来说，布顿试图带入他广告中的理想化食物图像，
don't cut it in a world that's now totally saturated with food porn. While Budein's commercials often zoomed in so close to food that you couldn't see the space around it, tabletop directors like Fugelstad now frame their food in a space that you might see out in the world Like at a restaurant or a barbecue. You know when you dig into a lasagna Do you want it to sauce to go all over the place when you to taco or stuff got to fall out? Yeah, so let's shoot that You know let it the flavors mix. It's alright. It's what tastes good But the thing to remember is this on the set of a food commercial everything But the thing to remember is this, on the set of a food commercial, everything, everything is highly orchestrated and contrived, even if the ultimate effect feels somewhat natural.
在一个现在完全被食物色情饱和的世界里，根本行不通。虽然布顿的广告经常放大到离食物太近，以至于你看不到它周围的空间，但像富格尔斯塔德这样的桌面导演现在把他们的食物框在一个你可能在世界上看到的空间里，比如在餐厅或烧烤架上。你知道当你吃千层面时，你想要酱汁到处都是吗？当你吃塔可饼时，东西会掉出来吗？是的，所以让我们拍那个。你知道，让味道混合。没关系。这就是好吃的味道。但要记住的是，在食品广告的片场，一切，一切都是高度编排和人为的，即使最终的效果感觉有些自然。
Because a 30 second TV spot by a firm like McGuffin can cost literally hundreds of thousands of dollars, so it's got to do one thing to make it all worthwhile. Sell a lot of food. I would say the number one rule in food advertising is that the first taste is always with the eyes. So you're trying to create a shot that makes somebody's a salivate. This is Terry O'Reilly again and he's fascinated by the links people go to sell something. He tells a story about working on a commercial for a hamburger company and watching an actor do take after take, biting into a hamburger and then gazing into the camera with a look of total satisfaction on his face.
因为像McGuffin这样的公司制作的30秒电视广告可能花费数十万美元，所以它必须做一件事才能让这一切都值得。卖出很多食物。我想说食品广告的第一条规则是第一口总是用眼睛吃的。所以你试图创造一个让某人流口水的镜头。这是特里·奥莱利，他着迷于人们为了卖东西而付出的努力。他讲了一个关于为一个汉堡公司制作广告的故事，看着一个演员一遍又一遍地拍摄，咬一口汉堡，然后带着完全满足的表情凝视镜头。
Then you cut and then there's the spit pale right beside the actor and then they just spit it right into the pale. You know, cut And you watch that happen 40 times or 30 times or 20, and it's so hilarious to me, just the mechanics of advertising. The illusion and the reality of creating it, that's exactly it in a nutshell. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Danny Lewis, Delaney Hall, and Avery Trufflement.
然后你喊停，演员旁边就有吐痰桶，他们就把东西直接吐进桶里。你知道，喊停。你看着这种情况发生40次或30次或20次，这对我来说太搞笑了，这就是广告的机制。幻觉和创造它的现实，这就是本质。99%隐形本周由丹尼·刘易斯、德莱尼·霍尔和艾弗里·特拉弗尔门制作。
With Katie Mingle, Sam Greenspan, Cherifuse, F Kurt Colestead, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Terry O'Reilly, who hosts Under the Influence on the CBC. We'll have a link to it on our website. We are a project of 91.7 KLW San Francisco in Produced under the offices of Arxine, an architecture and interiors for in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, Instagram and Spotify, but to find out more about this story, including
还有凯蒂·明格尔、萨姆·格林斯潘、谢里·福斯、F·库尔特·科尔斯特德和我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢特里·奥莱利，他在CBC主持《受影响》。我们会在我们的网站上提供链接。我们是旧金山91.7 KLW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心的Arxine建筑和室内设计办公室下制作。你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目并点赞。我们都在Twitter、Instagram和Spotify上，但要了解更多关于这个故事的信息，包括
cool pictures and links and listen to all the episodes of 99% Invisible. You must go to 99pi.org. Radio Tempia. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
很酷的图片和链接，并收听99%隐形的所有剧集。你必须去99pi.org。Radio Tempia。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。